[Music]
they're the pride of the British Empire
no not Queen Elizabeth and the royal
family but these top dogs what could be
more British than collies like this
beardy where's the head
here's my
all corgis the Queen's favorite
four-legged friends
[Music]
what makes this dog so British that's a
steer it has style
probably at least I think so it's big
mouth and it's weatherproof
at this dog show in the German state of
Brandenburg they're honoring British
style dogs are awarded points on their
looks build gait and personality India a
13 year old beardy is a veteran what
makes this breed so special there Billy
but beardy won't obey as quickly as a
sheepdog instead he'll think why does my
master want me to come good reason then
he'll come a partner with a mind of his
own how to predict and that's the
problem
UK breeders are proud to be British and
even prouder brexit ears says Sarah Boyd
from Germany's Club for British herding
dogs
so after brexit regulations for dogs
entering the UK unlikely to be tightened
canines might have to spend weeks in
quarantine of course there are really
good breeders there and you'd like to
use their stud dogs they have other
genetic material than what we have here
if they can't go to the UK these dogs
might not get to mate how shocking will
Germany's dog population soon be
comprised of just duck swans and German
Shepherds India the beardy now in the
ring needn't worry about that with her
13 years she's a senior citizen but
folks here will also miss the
camaraderie with their British
counterparts some travelled to
Birmingham each year to craft the famous
dog show
it's about fulfilling a dream I'm crying
because I wanted to do that once in my
life
even if we don't win we can say we were
there it's sad
but cheer up and the countries also have
nice dogs and as far as breeding goes
there's always artificial insemination
though for owners who prefer their dogs
mate the old-fashioned way it's bye-bye
Britain
[Music]